like this is eliminate we work together
though and the crazy ones yes we did
okay so the last time you know each
other I was like kind of dancing
awkwardly and inappropriately on you and
a scene so it's nice to just see you
casually it is so good to see you he's
so awesome on the shoot very nice I hate
acting the only reason why I said yes is
cuz all y'all in it and I was like wait
I can't pass this up you would not know
you did a great job you're very nice but
I love you though you on that show you
were selling products I remember it's
the pilot and I found out what the whole
show is about and you were selling
products but you actually did that in
life before acting yeah exactly on the
show the show was about it was about an
ad agency and we were selling that
product and we pitched you that was
really fun and in real life I grew up
working at my dad's shoe store women's
shoe store I said it like that because
usually you know women like shoes I
think I'm similar yeah I wasn't I wasn't
like a toe touch I just and I would you
know say these look great my I was like
40 knows my dad's store all right so do
you still get like the employee discount
like for your wife my wife does okay our
closet is basically her shoes and then I
have like two t-shirts it's she gets to
get some pretty sweet shoes yeah his
shoes are awesome they always fit yeah
yeah unless you have children and your
feet grow oh my gosh trying to get rid
of all my shoes poor dude is sandwiched
by us I could
about shoes Watchmen and she had some
guys out here no cuz it was a viral
thing yeah we're talking about someone
sliding through the gutters yeah
wondering if it was CGI if it was an
actual like stuntman can you tell us now
if someone sliding through this tiny
gutter like Slenderman he went right
yeah he was running and then mask on
everything
and then slid through the gutter by the
way without without contact never do
that yeah without contact the show
sounds totally wild yes and he was
wearing great shoes good shoes amazing
amazing shoes I think there was a lot of
CGI in that yeah I think there's because
I'm about to try it tomorrow don't worry
those shoes well let's talk about the
watchman what's it about watchman is
about it's based on a graphic novel and
basically being a superhero is outlawed
they're basically like vigilantes I am
so in and it's really dark and so Damon
Lindelof is the creator of our show
which is on HBO and he took that idea
and he took the graphic novel and this
now is set like 30 years after the
original graphic novel set in a
dystopian kind of like alternate
universe United States of America and
it's nine episodes and it's it's a wild
ride it's really they're still like
trying to help people is that the thing
is that what happened that's right
okay show opens up and there is a murder
that takes place and it's like clue yeah
it's like clue yeah exactly
do you like Golden Girls clue like the
other night Golden Girls somebody got it
for me and my son was like on my clue we
could original you find the golden
Dorothy
anyway about your show the super here
still want to help but they don't want
to get caught yes so it basically if the
superheroes are outlawed and then the
police it takes place in Tulsa Oklahoma
and the police in Tulsa Oklahoma are all
masked and so it deals a lot with you
know the idea of wearing a mask and what
that means and but this event takes
place and you basically spend nine
episodes in this world figuring out what
happened and its job yeah it's it's it
was an amazing experience
filming the show and shooting it and we
didn't play Golden Girls I couldn't find
the original are you dying to do like a
rom-com or something we did the cut the
show that we did together was was comedy
yeah but you I just mean like a bit like
a movie like I feel like Ron Kahn's kind
of died I love crazy rich and I bring
the rom-com second by the way well we
have to take a break and we'll figure
out this movie while that's happening I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this